welcome to this video hello Rico
Frederico okay let's do some simple
stuff playing a quiet opening get some
Catalan maybe yeah we indeed transposed
to a kettle on yeah b6 is not very
precise in this position for more than
one reason this is one of them
really this is possible did I do yeah I
wonder ever confuse to move or him okay
let's just continue even if it's not the
the most precise way to play a slow
should be ok em yeah the pawns are
usually a problem for black it's not
regular hanging porn structure let's see
mmm takes and III well okay I really
want to want to play it in a simple way
okay 93 ultimately trying to prove that
c6 is a weakness
hmm yeah okay so he's not going to be
able to play be five yeah I have night
hmm many moves actually am Bishop aged
three years also quite quite nice
okay hmm I wonder I can't mean taking
it's not bad I'm talking about getting
it to e5 it looks even better hmm it's
both interesting and let's do this okay
so
you can also just double maybe I should
double I'm not sure yeah a threatened
Bishop takes d5
Luke c6 was also interesting
not not sure him bury em I mean this is
a very nice position but it's a it's
difficult to determine when to change
the structure because while you're
you're so good in the structure that
that that is on the board that you have
a you have a hard time to really change
something
okay i can just do you can just drop
back or be higher both the good think
okay let's do this t5 and term and b5
saying
yeah I think night cheeks night x is
probably right Knight takes b6 is also
an idea not right now what is in the
position this kind of IDM with
discoveries
95 chickens is coming take here Bishop
c6 he is really funny okay so he's just
playing now four nights if for him or
this one not quite sure okay this check
check but I should be should be quick
and black resides champ I know this and
how he did something wrong in the
precise opening moves but it was a
pretty pretty nice position around here
why it starts to be a little bit better
yeah this is this kind of thing it's
it's difficult now for him to to change
something about the structure and [ __ ]
porn would be a weakness this is a
really really question weakening the
whole structure I don't know okay that's
easy here f6 yeah 95 he was worried
about 95 but the the light squares hmm
should be too was even stronger
according to the comp we are just
directed doubling possible it's really
are many many ways forward that look
that look attractive oh it's stunned at
the computer only gives you a point 5
for what maybe this is a tougher
position than I thought here Roxy 6
comes into consideration i was thinking
about it but i wasn't sure this is yet
the right moment to do that the thing is
that swell
it's a little bit weird because he gets
rid of his bad bishop but well you break
through here and I mean something like
this this is possibly this is falling as
well you get two pawns and still very
very active play it is it is probably
good yeah but I wasn't I wasn't really
sure about it so H for King here for ya
I was playing it as safe as possible
let's say and hear be fighters should
really fall apart of 1.5 m yeah but I
didn't play it well I have this
moonshine yeah this I should have seen
actually it's not what exactly exactly
jacket it's just kind of thing okay well
this is this is not bad but not as
convincing check no yeah I'm winning
again yeah at least at least gotta win
in here okay well thanks for watching